cult film favorite Bruce Campbell has
long been just as prolific on the small
screen as he has in movies most notably
as a series regular for all seven
seasons of the Spy based 2007 to 2013
action series burn notice but the
television role that's a lot more in
line with what people expect from
Campbell came nearly 15 years earlier
when he starred in the western sci-fi
comedy The Adventures of Brisco County
Jr in the show Campbell played Brisco
County a wise cracking Bounty Hunter who
doesn't seem particularly good at his
job but somehow always seems to fumble
his way out of trouble created by the
writing team behind Indiana Jones in the
Last Crusade the show definitely has
elements of that film series with clever
writing and consistently satisfying
action throughout so what went wrong
well it was perhaps a bit too subversive
for the time and Campbell wasn't quite
the household name yet that he'd
eventually become with his loyal but
still relatively Niche fan base not yet
large enough to sustain a pricey network
television action adventure show